efectivamente
hay miedo hecho que los profesores que
en francia son muy importantes porque
están vistos como unos defensores de la
república es son los que enseñan los
valores de la república a los niños
fueron realmente impactados por este
atentado que fue muy brusco además muy
bárbaro en plena calle entonces hubo
realmente un don de hecho que muy grande
dentro del cuerpo de los profesores que
son los que defienden digamos los
valores de la república en francia la
libertad de expresión está inscrita en
su adn no hay que olvidar que en francia
hay muy poquitas censura y por eso pues
no se prohíbe las caricaturas de mahoma
y summer patxi habló de la libertad de
expresión habló de la importancia de la
laicidad en la sociedad francesa antes
de ser decapitado entonces realmente la
libertad de expresión en francia muy
poquitas veces
si está atacada si no por este asunto de
las caricaturas de mahoma entonces hay
una relación muy fuerte entre censura
island y eso obviamente pues hace que se
nutren unos discursos de extrema derecha
sobre lo lo malo que puede ser la
islamización de la sociedad francesa más
aún en un escenario electoral con el
cual estamos en este momento bueno
vuelvo a la campaña en contra del
profesor en redes sociales que estaba
mencionando porque esto se podría
considerar también como libertad de
expresión pero al mismo tiempo es lo que
lleva a cometer de alguna manera una
antesala del crimen en contra de la
libertad de expresión que es asesinar a
alguien solo por mostrar estas
caricaturas de mahoma cómo se interpreta
esta contradicción
no hay que olvidar que entonces fue un
estudiante que relató a su papá que al
día siguiente iba a tener una clase
sobre libertad de expresión y fue el
papá de esta estudiante que empieza
entonces a montar toda la historia monta
un vídeo en redes sociales diciendo
tenemos que hacer algo no podemos dejar
este profesor hacer eso y ahí digamos
que la dinámica de las redes sociales
hace que hay un efecto bola de nieve y
que este vídeo se transmite cien veces
mil veces diez mil veces por las redes
sociales y hasta que le llega entonces a
este desequilibra a un un checheno que
estaba buscando hacer algo en contra de
que quería atacar la repubblica y que
aquí encuentra una una causa digamos
para que va a buscar el profesor para
hacer eso entonces si tenemos una
contradicción efectivamente hay que no
hay que olvidar que la libertad de
expresión siempre tiene que estar
limitada por el respeto a la vida y por
el respeto a la seguridad de los demás
entonces en este caso pues tenemos un
profesor que es defensor de él
leyes de la república que fue que fue
atacado justamente por enseñar a sus
estudiantes el valor de la libertad de
expresión pero en internet ahí
circularon otras ideas dentro del marco
de la libertad de expresión pero que
iban en contra de los principios de la
república entonces hay una contradicción
clara que hasta ahora la sociedad
francesa no ha podido resolver pero el
asesinato lo cometió un joven
radicalizado desde entonces se han
tomado medidas para prevenir o combatir
la radicalización en francia si de hecho
en francia estamos siempre con el plan
de visita que es un plan contra el
terrorismo que está activo todo el
tiempo
y además estamos en un escenario
preelectoral no hay que olvidar que
manuel marco va a terminar su mandato
del año anterior el año próximo que
seguramente va a ser candidato a su
reelección pero que en este momento hay
una proliferación de discursos de
extrema derecha hay un candidato de
extrema derecha que está ganando
muchísimo peso que es en el que se move
y que está diciendo en francia por
ejemplo hay censura no se respeta la
libertad de expresión aparte en el
momento que yo hablo del islam y de lo
peligroso que es el islam y como la
sociedad francesa se está islamizando y
cómo nos van a reemplazar
estos población inmigrantes sobre los
franceses digamos de
corte más cristiano y blanco y aquí hay
una censura porque
francia no quiere escuchar este tipo de
discursos entonces estamos en pleno
ambiente digamos de islamofobia de
proliferación de discursos islamofóbicos
y además no hay que olvidar que estamos
en también haciendo el proceso de los
terroristas que perpetraron los
atentados del bat a clown y del 13 de
noviembre entonces la sociedad estaban
yendo digamos en este escenario y en
este debate de qué hacer con el islam
qué hacer con la libertad de expresión
claro señor ariza muchas gracias por
compartir nos este análisis en france 24